my guest tonight is a hilarious comedian
whose new book
bull twit and whatnot the online
ramblings of george wallace
is available now please welcome the
master
george wallace george how are you
oh my god i'm talking to conan
o'brien yes hello have you been doing tv
now
28 years 28 years yeah and this is my
first
time ever talking to you that's right i
am so
elated i'm so happy i'm finally
conan you got five minutes ago
after 28 years i get five minutes you
have five minutes ago
all right here we go listen i need you
to talk we used to live in the same
building in new york city that's right
you said 28 years ago you said come on
do the show that's been 28 years ago
yeah and um
i guess you were pissed at me because i
lived on the top floor you lived in
i lived in a very a nice building on the
west side and you lived on the top floor
and i lived down
down where they put the irish people
down near the bottom
so i was very i was very bitter about
that uh but yeah i used to see you all
the time and i remembered you'd go on
dave's show
all the time dave letterman's show all
the time i used to go on dave letterman
show with a pad
and uh with my you know uh so long ago
with my yellow pad i could still keep it
with me
according i've been i've been doing
comedy so long people are accusing me of
stealing my own [ __ ]
[Laughter]
in 1993 i used to take the pad on
television i went on arsenio hall and i
said i got some new jokes here
that might be funny might not i got to
do letterman tomorrow night i got to
make sure this stuff is funny
wait a minute so you would try your
material out on arsenio
to see if it was good enough to go on
letterman that must have pissed off
arsenio
maybe it did i didn't care the thing
about it
the thing about it when i would do the
joke i would say you know and people
have accused me of stealing this and i
did this in 1993. yeah
i would do a joke the joke would work
real good i just write down
joke works real good i do the next joke
works real good now right next joke
needs work needs work i do the next joke
real good fourth joke i do joke's funny
audience sucks they would go crazy and
just
that's how i became uh to be the guy
with the yellow pad the legal pad
because if you don't put them on a real
legal yellow pad
the jokes are not legal it doesn't
doesn't it's not legal i know that i
you know what my method is i test the
jokes and on every one i say
crowd sucked it's never my fault it's
always crowd
sucked nothing wrong never my fault it's
funny
yeah you know it's funny and we have a
we're so blessed to be able to do
funny business especially in this day
and time to be able to
um make the world laugh and i just think
that's great and i'm so blessed to do
what i do
uh with this epidemic going on and and
all i do
no i'm just blessed all i do is just lie
i just lie i got the greatest job at all
i just make up [ __ ]
and they pay me that's you're right it's
funny i never thought about it uh
jokes are just they're pretty much just
lies we're just
we're just bullshitting we're getting
paid we're very lucky people how
are you during quarantine what are you
doing how are you handling it first of
all how are you handling the quarantine
well let me put it like this i've been
in atlanta since march 14 when we shut
down my show i was shooting a show with
netflix
and i shut it down i'm glad because i'm
health conscious and i came to atlanta
i'm handling it i'm
i'm locked up i'm locked down i'm
quarantined i'm
insulated isolated whatever i don't go
anywhere
nobody's come to my home and i don't let
anybody in
every now and then all that like sarah
lee and jimmy dean
[Laughter]
old friends ben and jerry uh jack
daniels can come over
you know you want you want the good
friends to come over yeah i appreciate
it
but uh yeah i've been handling pretty
well but i've changed my living habits
i'm just
too cautious and uh social distancing
like
not too long ago my daughter came by to
see me and i live on the 25th floor and
uh
and she was in the parking lot across
the street i waved at my ass and i said
hey
as close as you're gonna get social
distancing see you keep moving
keep moving so some things have changed
with me uh conan my
my grooming is not that good really
my feet man when i when i'm able to
get a pedicure i'm going to have to
probably stop by home depot and we're
talking about sandpaper
[Laughter]
chisel
you'll need a buzz saw you'll need a
buzz saw you're going to need
[Laughter]
so this pandemic has been bad but i've
been it allows me to
stay at home and write jokes i like
writing jokes i can tell you're
you're loaded for bear you've got a ton
of good stuff and another thing you
mentioned you're in atlanta
have you ever been in atlanta yes i have
yeah i did uh i've done some
i've done some shows there and i
absolutely loved it absolutely it's a
beautiful place
i was talking to uh i did uh trevor noah
last week
right you know and he's from africa and
i had him to admit
when he got off the airplane in atlanta
i said i bet you never seen that many
black people
people in your life have you they got
more black people in atlanta
africans get off the airplane in atlanta
they go holy sh
listen to me you come to atlanta it's
it's amazing
and it's good things are happening in
the city you know atlanta is the number
one movie making capital in the world of
the world
yep we made that movement and making
another movie what is it black panther
too
and um you know when they initially made
the black panther movie
uh they they wanted to make it in africa
and they went over to africa to make the
movie but when they got to africa
they found they didn't have enough black
people so
they had to call delta and fly them
right back to atlanta
so there's a lot of black people when
you come here you're just it's a lot of
fun in atlanta we make things happen
here
and the boating here was great and uh i
mean when you think about it
georgia has played a pivotal role in
politics recently
i mean that's it's got to be neat that
you're living there you're part of
history
georgia blue baby georgia blue we
changed the nation
we um it's just been uh crazy in the
last
month you know what georgia did here's
the joke i wrote that is my favorite
show
a black man and a jew walked into a bar
and the bartender says may i help you
centaurs
now additionally that joke was written
back in the early 90s
and clinton eastwood heard the joke he
used it in one of his movies now the
original joke i wrote now you got to be
a comedian to really
you got to know culminate to understand
this joke it was about
making a long story short i i'm gonna do
this for you i don't normally talk like
this this was when i was
1993. to make a long story short
two jews a mexican and a black walked
into a bar
the bartender said y'all get there
were looking in the orders and people
that are into commenting they went crazy
you know that was johnny carson's
favorite joke johnny carson that was his
favorite joke i know i i uh
god god it's make a long story short and
also let's just cut to the chase
[Laughter]
you know are you would you say you're
adept at technology because i have found
in this time of quarantine you got to be
pretty good
with computers you got to be able to get
on zoom
are you able to do all this stuff no i'm
doing pretty good i'm doing it you know
i love what i do
the new um this new age is technical and
i
really like tick-tock time because i do
stupid stuff every day and i just want
to
you know i want to put on tomorrow i'm
going to put on tick-tock
trump going to jail chuck on the jail
yes he is trump going to jail
[Laughter]
and then it's a dance craze yeah yeah
but
i shouldn't have said that because i
don't i don't do trump jokes anymore so
you know
by the way we need to have a garage sale
too because they got all these trump
jokes around here stinking up thing i
need to get rid of him you know i've
been happy
not talking about him i have to say
um i know that some comedians say i'm
going to miss doing the trump jokes and
i think i
i mean i tried to not talk about him
even the last year of his presidency i
just got tired of it and so i'm enjoying
i'm enjoying this time i think it's
going to be a good time for comedy
actually
i don't know about that i don't know
about that i mean i'm doing right now
with it with the with the last week what
what has happened in america on the 21st
i felt like a a
free slave you know i just felt just
great and then i have uh of course i'm
democrat officer biden but
biden uh i like him but
i don't like him i mean this guy is i
mean he's doing
some great stuff but it's not good for
us comedian
i got no joke on it i got no joke on
fighting
you know what that was the same you know
i remembered us talking about this when
obama was president
he was he was tough for comedians
because he's this
uh handsome smart uh you know
uh competent uh man who's working hard
to make the country a better place
and um you know where's the joke in that
but i think
that's a joke out but you know what i'll
say as a patriot
i'll take the competent president over
the jokes and if it means that my
business suffers
so be it my business does not need to
suffer i'm having problems with fighting
he walks in there yesterday using his
four-letter word
plan now when the last time we heard the
word been
four years i mean that's good for the
plan but it ain't funny
that's not funny he walks in with his
cova team yesterday
doctors scientists epidemiologists
infectious disease specialist with a
plan
well he didn't come in with family
members and some guy
push a pillow with mypillow.com guy
i mean it's good you're right this is a
terrible terrible time for american
comedy
and that's funny you know he's doing
that and and this guy look at him what
he's doing
to top all of that off making full
complete sentences when the last time we
heard
but it ain't funny yeah yeah you're
right we got to get we got to move him
out
uh it's it's he hasn't been on a golf
course it's been a whole week
how are you supposed to run a country
and make a country better yeah without
being not on the golf course
you know freeing your mind and
[Laughter]
it's not funny well i'm sorry i'm sorry
you're right this is a terrible time
terrible time for our country hey let me
ask you about your old friend you are
best friends with jerry seinfeld
you guys were roommates i think for over
a decade
you guys were roommates he's an idiot
now you know
he's an idiot huh yeah he seems not a
smart guy is he
oh don't you ever say that in front of
him because like seinfeld like he's uh
eight years in a row with one year on
fortune magazine he was the number one
money-making comedian
in the world in the world kevin hart
beat him out one year
and so he think he knows everything and
he's first to tell me because i'm the
one who tell him shut up
you have no idea what you're talking
about everybody else all the other
committees yeah jerry yeah whatever he
says it goes good
i don't take that i talk to him like a
little brother i tell him to shut up you
don't know everything you think you know
this you don't know that
he tells me check the list check the
list he's number one on the list that's
all
that's his back up check the list he's
got too much money i mean you and i
we're doing real
good we're doing real good but yeah he's
he's he's up here
different these rich people man
i go to the house i mean just too rich i
go to his house on the island and the
land and the property is so big
i mean when you're punching the security
code at the gate
waze is still giving you direction to
the house
[Laughter]
just to get from the gate to the front
door you need ways
in 2000 feet you will have reached
and you get in the house he doesn't like
me to talk about this how rich
they are and i'm going to catch hell for
doing this but i'm at his house
i got up at three o'clock in the morning
i went to pee i
come back my bed is made
and there's a guy said no chocolate on
my pillow
it's crazy but i i do take advantage of
his friendship
yeah well you should you should and you
know what he needs you
because he's got too many yes people
around him telling him he's a genius
he needs you george he needs a guy like
you telling him
you don't know what you're talking about
and you've got too much money that's
that's what
45 years 45 years best friends for 45
years we started a club called catch
rise and start in the coming strip in
new york city
but we've been best friends for 45 years
i wish
everybody had a friend like seinfeld and
it's just amazing um
and yes i'm actually the real roommate
i'm actually the real george and we've
been for 13 years we were roommates and
i was best man in his wedding and i'm
the father of his kids also
[Laughter]
hey george that's been obvious for some
time
when you see the kids you go they look a
little dark
hey i want to uh i want to make sure i
mention this because this is really
funny
bull twit and whatnot you got a copy i
got a copy
uh this is fine i did not send you a
hard copy this is the hard copy
i'm more proud of the quality of the
book than i am of some of the jokes in
there
you know what i do hey listen colin i'm
so stupid this is the hardcover right
when you buy this book this book is 140
and people i do stupid stuff because i'm
stupid
140 because of 140 characters and and
[Laughter]
people are buying the book because it's
a great table piece and it's the quality
as you can see the quality of your paper
cover
is really good there yeah you know i i
like a paperback because
uh i get nervous if the book is uh if
it's too fancy i feel like i don't
deserve it so i'm i'm comfortable with
the paperback well you don't deserve it
that's why i sent you this one
go ahead yeah you sent me the paperback
thanks a lot
we used to live in the same building and
i i get the paperback uh can i read some
of these because i really like them i
like this one
i'll straight up link with someone from
grindr and grind with someone from
linkedin i really don't give a [ __ ]
about that i don't give a [ __ ]
you know what i'll eat cupcakes out of a
pan and pancakes out of a cup
i don't play by the rules okay i like
this one i like the really silly ones
just saying
sweater vests are gonna have to pick a
side when the [ __ ] goes down between
sweaters and vests
guess what there's some really good uh i
like the
the the there's some silly strange ones
here's one i don't play the whack-a-mole
game at carnivals because it reminds me
of when my family was attacked by moles
and i was unable to defend them
you know what that must be a really
funny joke because that's also
pat oswalt's funniest joke oh really
yeah i'm just trying to make you pee a
little bit from your eye
[Laughter]
can i say you have an idea i mean some
of these also are really good
uh you know i started my career as a
sketch writer
i had to write sketches long before i
had to write jokes and
there's great sketch ideas in here this
is a tweet you sent that i think would
make a great sketch i'd like to see this
happen why do football players only
dance when good [ __ ] happens
just once i want to see a quarterback
throw an interception
and do a sad interpretive dance
[Laughter]
wouldn't that be nice no b but i mean
that's a funny sketch i would love to
see someone do that that's a great idea
it really is a great idea and you know
when you see these tweets that i do in
the book
it's not my tweets it's the replies the
replies i'm going to write
more bullet twit volume two and whatnot
like i said shout out to the top five
bells in the world
so i did liberty bell i did tinker bell
i did save by the bell
i did a few more bells and then somebody
hit me with you never heard of taco
that drives me crazy little things like
a taco bell yes
and the next book i'm going to add some
of those replies like if i were to do
the top five
coves in the world codes the top five
codes in the world you see this from
coming aren't you sure you got costco
yeah you got uh uh co-mingling
you got uh co-op and i guess number five
would be
conan yes how about number one instead
of number five
let's go don't push it don't push it
[Laughter]
you're pushing i you know what you know
what george i got greedy
uh i got i got ahead of myself and i i
apologize
i did want to bring up something that's
very important which is
um you got vaccinated and you
feel very strongly about telling people
that you got vaccinated and getting the
word out that they need to get
vaccinated why don't you tell us about
that
well i did that because you know uh
black i get it especially
for black people and uh people of color
that's a little skeptical
about getting the vaccine but we need to
get this and get it done
especially here in atlanta like i said
we have more black people atlanta than
anywhere in the world
so i went and got to vaccination and
it's just important because
we've had a lot of mistrust with the uh
medical
community and the government yes and so
that's why it's my job to get out and
promote
and uh and i got my first shot and i had
no
no reactions whatsoever i i
i got the shot i sat there for 15
minutes and i'm good and i'm ready to
get the
second one as soon as possible and uh if
you
if it's possible when johnson johnson
comes out with the uh
you know only one injection that's
really good to get now
johnson johnson the black people should
have no problem with that
that's johnson and johnson that's a
black company
that's one of the great black companies
of all time of all time
you're the black and decker well one of
them was black seals and robot
back in the day robot was black but
george i gotta say you are on thousand
and justin
you are on you are on fire you uh you're
on fire
uh you know quarantine has not slowed
you down
uh one second i am honored to have you
on the show
i'm glad you i'm glad you got over your
conan bias uh and decided to give us a
shot
you still you're still going to get it
you're still going to get it but you can
get this book at george wallace dot
george wallace.net i didn't go to amazon
because they take happy monday this time
i thought let me make all the money
because i
be thinking
[Laughter]
all right so that's right go to uh you
can go to georgewallace.com
georgewallace.net it's a really funny
book and especially right now in our
lives
we need to laugh and who better who
better to take us there than uh than mr
george wallace sir
thank you and when you stop laughing you
stop living
my name is george wallace i love you and
there's absolutely nothing you can do
about it
no i'm going to get up i'm going to get
a lawyer and fight this thing
i consider you a very good friend of
mine so i always in my shows of talking
to my very best friends
always like to end with your punk ass
hey george thank you so much and take
care no thank you sir let's do it again